so this is our revolution yeah this is
our revolution said you and Alison
taught us a lot in zombies you taught us
that no one should be kept isolated for
who they are or what happened before
they were born a lot has changed since
they built the barrier 50 years ago you
also taught us and all of Seabrook that
keeping people separate is wrong and you
taught Addison how important it is to be
yourself hey all those lessons to remind
us of another Disney Channel movie I've
learned that you can't live in fear fans
are quick to point out the similarities
between zombies and descendants but
these franchises are even more connected
than you thought keep watching for five
secret connections between zombies - and
descendants three a world of isolation
in descendants three the world is still
pretty isolated
even though mal and the core four have
proven that decays aren't all bad the
barrier is still up they were only
letting in four more V Ches instead of
all of them in zombies - thinks are
still isolated as well the zombies still
live in Sambi town
even though they can come and go to see
Brooke as they please from what we can
tell these werewolves haven't been
allowed in before where have they been
is there a werewolf town it's pretty
weird that both of these worlds have so
much segregation even though they're
modern it's things like this that
suggest they're occurring in the same
universe apparently in this universe
segregation is a totally normal thing
people are only just beginning to
question it zombies are students at
Seabrook - Bucky we sure hope that
Seabrook learns to accept the werewolves
and let everyone in auradon certainly
did in descendant 3 who's really evil in
descendants everyone thinks that all the
children of villains are evil but by the
third movie most people have gotten over
that but there are still people who
think the barrier should stay closed
Audrey her grandmother Leah and Chad are
still low key against the V Ches you'd
really rather have a PTO
turning me in zombies too there are
still going to be plenty of people who
are skeptical about zombies the town has
group zombies and monsters together for
over 50 years that sort of mindset
doesn't go away overnight and now
werewolves are coming seabrooke is so
new at acceptance lucky things can
change lots of people are going to think
these werewolves are evil monsters and
some of these biases might come from
zombies we can see lots of issues
popping up between said Eliza and the
others the Seebeck have room for more
supernatural people we hope they learn
the same lesson auradon dead
picture perfect there's one compelling
fact that makes us think auradon in
Seabrook exist in the same universe and
that is how picture-perfect life seemed
before the outsiders arrived it's so
good to finally meet you all let's look
at the similarities in auradon
everything is green and bright it always
seems to be sunny everyone wears pastels
or bright colors in Seabrook everyone
has perfectly manicured houses and lawns
the only people who don't wear pastel
colors are the zombie patrol guards this
is what is seen as normal and good in
both worlds anyone wearing dark colors
is seen as bad and the Isle of the Lost
in zombie town have a lot of
similarities in their decor but that's
not how the real world works at all it's
really strange that both of these places
have the same definition of normal
people here hate anything that's
different
Seabrook may just be some lost town
thousands of miles away from Oregon
Outsiders save the day
mal saves the day once again in
descendants three she's the only one who
can stop Audrey and this time she
doesn't have evj or Carlos's help they
were turned to stone moments before the
battle she did get help from uma and uma
is even more of an outsider than mal
[Applause]
in psalm bees addison felt like an
outcast but still managed to convince
Seabrook to accept Somme bees and then
the zombie saved the cheer competition
thanks to Zoey this finally turns
everyone onto the zombie side we brought
everyone together and we threw an
awesome block party zombies too has a
new group of outsiders and the
werewolves could potentially help save
the day we're pretty sure that Addison
is going to be the one leading the
change the werewolves will help Addison
change the minds of the zombies and the
humans this is going to be great for
everyone it's cool how people who never
fit in find their place by making waves
Addison and mal have a lot in common
fight for what's right
both descendants three and zombies two
are all about fighting for what's right
and we mean that people are going to be
literally fighting there's a lot of
disagreement in descendents three now
decides to close the barrier permanently
and the barrier will be closed for good
she lies to her best friends and they're
so angry when they find out but mal
didn't want to mess up the life she had
found in Oregon Addison and Zed disagree
about the werewolves in zombies too the
main theory is that sad is going to be
the one who doesn't accept them he has
found a pretty good life in Seabrook and
that is going to be worried about
messing up the newfound acceptance for
zombies and while we understand his
worries Addison is probably going to be
pushing for acceptance she was the first
person in all of Seabrook to accept the
zombies I meant welcome to the cafeteria
she'll definitely be that person again
for the werewolves when mal realized
that she was wrong in descendants three
the barrier came down and her people
were finally encouraged to live as one
Seabrook and auradon are super connected
what theories do you have about these
two places let us know in the comments
thanks for watching be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more awesome videos we'll
see you next time on the things
you